This show is sponsored by Bill aand Melinda Gates
I have some bad news to tell you, we will all die.
In fact, an average of 1.8 people per second will die.
The most important thing you will die is your age.
Next, there will be statistics that will tell you about your possible cause of death.
Let us start from the opposite of those over 70 years old.
In the world, this stage is the age at which nearly half of the people will die.
The overwhelming cause of death of people over the age of 70 is a disease of the heart.
If you are an American between the ages of 45 and 64, cancer is the leading cause of death.
In 2016, 8.9 million people worldwide died of cancer, more than 5.7 million more than in 1990.
Wait, why do people who get cancer suddenly increase so much?
Because our population is increasing and our life expectancy is extended, so many people get cancer.
If you are dead between 25 and 44 years old
In the United States, the main cause of death is misuse of poisoning.
Maybe this sounds weird
In fact, the term "mistaken poisoning" also includes drug abuse.
From 1999 to 2016, the number of people killed in drug abuse in the United States has tripled.
The main reason is because of the opioid crisis.
The latest data from 2017 shows that that year was the worst year for drug abuse deaths in American history.
In fact, the number of people killed by drugs in 2017 is more than the number of casualties of the US military in the Iraq war plus the Vietnam War.
However, this is not the main cause of death in the world.
In South Africa, the leading cause of death at this stage is AIDS.
In Brazil, the first cause of death is homicide.
In the United States between the ages of 15 and 24, the main cause of death is a car accident.
Especially in the months after I got my driver’s license, I was more likely to have a car accident.
Moreover, 53% of accidents occur on Friday, Saturday or Sunday.
Compared to female driving, the probability of death in a male driving car accident is doubled.
And the number of teenagers wearing seat belts is the least
They are more likely to speed
And they are closer to other cars than normal people.
At 5 to 14 years old, the main cause of death is malaria.
Plasmodium is a single-celled parasitic microorganism called Plasmodium
It is transmitted through mosquitoes
The complexity of malaria parasites makes vaccines very difficult to make
But recent problems have shown promising results
In 2017, 5.4 million children under the age of 5 died
The main cause of death is a wide range of neonatal disorders
After the tragedy, the child’s mortality rate has dropped sharply.
In 1990, every 11 children under the age of five had one unfortunate death.
But in 2017, it changed from every 11 to every 26
So you will "how" death will depend on when you "dead"
If you are in old age, heart disease can happen to you.
Having said that, the main cause of death 100 years ago was the flu.
So, how do we know how we will die in the future?
But we can do better with the help of science
Examined more than 40,000 voluntary DNA samples
Geneticists have discovered premature babies and the minerals they produce - selenium
The study found that mothers with this gene in pregnancy are more likely to have premature birth
15 million babies are born prematurely each year
And understand the reasons for these premature births is a very important factor
These babies have a higher risk of death in low-income countries
This and temporary solution is one of the most fascinating and amazing issues.
You can read the information from the Annual Letter of Bill and Melinda Gates' at GatesLetter.com.
In this year, they shared what they encountered at work.
The toilet included has not changed in this century.
And textbooks become obsolete
The surprising reason for these is that the information on these two things is actually very important.
You find these unexpected moments will help them help the world and make it better.
So go check out GatesLetter.com
Remember to press the subscription button to see my scientific film every Thursday (Chinese (Taiwan) subtitles by DCX (a kind of wandering lazy))